Well,
Sako doesn't have a day,
my father's council is off by my side
.
I'm going around the coffee shop [music] I got it, so if you come this far, you won't have to worry about chasing me Hey, why are you going to Paris?
He said that Prince Azami was trying to do the same thing to Erina as before
. I heard from father and mother about what Azami had done.
You always didn't reply to me
I know that, but
this time I won't let you
like this child No, no, no, boys and girls in this world run away from home
No
, but how can you go against your father?
It's nice to have a hangover, but where are you going?
It's impossible It
seems that the priest and my room aren't in the mansion of
fog either.
If you don't
think it's ugly, I think I'll
be the first to be suspected and get my feet on it if I don't have 10 minutes a month with the commercial Joe,
but
I won't put it in the corner on the same day